listen I want to start with congrats on
the first two episodes uh this is going
to be a big hit
um no no doubt and one of the reasons is
Taylor Sheridan everything he touches
just turns to platinum you know and so
I'm just curious what do you think it is
about his writing in in the way he makes
shows that resonates with so many people
well I think he really thinks about
transitions in people's lives and when
you're trying to
figure out who you are and that being a
person is complicated and it's nuanced
and I do think
um
you know I think he also you know in a
lot of his shows it's all older people
now kind of looking back on their lives
in certain ways and navigating through
that you know this Show's a little
different because Taylor had the initial
idea but handed the show off to Terence
winter so Terry wrote you know the show
and I've actually never met Taylor
Sheridan
so
um it's you know so this is a little
this is a different situation for Taylor
as well did anyone on set while you were
filming joke around what season will the
crossover go with Yellowstone
[Laughter]
um I believe there were definitely jokes
along that way or what's the prequel
what's the prequel to the prequel of
this you know what I mean and there'd be
like some very small like you know
character on the show and I'll be like
you know what season four it's a whole
new series based on that Barista you
know stuff like that how much did you
actually get told about the Arc of your
character because you played an
important part in the first two episodes
how much were you told when you signed
on this is what we're thinking you know
what I mean or is it sort of like it's
Stallone I I want to do this
um I just knew the first two episodes
and uh you know they were still writing
as we were going along so it was still
forming so you know we were all waiting
for episodes to see what was going to
happen because there was it was not all
set up before we started which is
you know wild yeah people don't realize
how much television is literally just
laying the track right in front as
you're walking it you know and I will
say I've never experienced anything like
this either I come from Comedy and
um you know either it's if it's
situational comedy there's not really
arcs because they're individual episodic
you know and my show I'm sorry I would
write every episode we were completely
locked script wise before we started day
one of shooting
so I've never been in this situation and
it's kind of nerve-wracking and you
really have to put Faith in the process
and go God I don't know what anyone else
is shooting my characters kind of by
themselves I don't know where I'm headed
here we go you know you really just have
to go I I know that these people are
extremely talented and Trust in that and
just go I'm with working with the best
people so if they can't do it
you know no one can I'm already out of
time I was going to ask you about
Stallone but I'm just going to leave it
there and say this is I know it's going
to be a big hit so congrats and uh you
know um for I'll talk to you at season
two have a great day you too